good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight there comes a time in every
presidential administration when the
people in charge realize they're not
really in control unforeseen events
arise in an instant every assumption
about the future changes heads of state
die wars erupted natural disasters to
send epidemics rage none of it was in
anybody's plan there's something about
human nature that prevents us from
preparing for this for abrupt and
radical change we pretend the unexpected
will never happen but there's something
in nature itself that reminds us it
inevitably will it's always a terrifying
realization the rise of the Chinese
coronavirus is that kind of moment the
virus is quickly becoming a global
pandemic ultimately it could kill
millions at the very least it will
reorder the global economy and change
our politics could the disease help
determine the outcome of our next
presidential election eight months from
now of course it could in fact it will
our leaders can't stop that like all
matters of life and death it is beyond
human power to affect but they can
respond to the threat in a way that
makes this country stronger not weaker
how can they do that
here's how the first step is to take the
virus seriously and to convince the
public that you are in 1918 Woodrow
Wilson's White House downplayed the
Spanish Influenza and refused to take
obvious precautions to slow its spread
Wilson had a pointless war in progress
in Europe to fight his generals couldn't
be distracted from that goal so the
government continued to ship men to
overcrowded army camps across the
country and to pack them on ships to
France the virus spread exponentially in
the end about 53,000 American soldiers
were killed in combat in that war at
least 675 thousand Americans died of the
flu could Wilson have prevented that
disaster well not entirely but by early
and decisive action he could have
improved America's odds so what does
effective action look like now well we
ought to be screening people when they
get off the planes from infected
countries that's not complicated it's
obvious but at the same time it is
hardly a solution we should be honest
about how much we can do to keep the
Chinese coronavirus from coming here a
hundred years ago the Spanish flu killed
a significant percentage of the
population in remote Aleutian Islands
and that was before air travel today the
entire world is
connected by hourly international
flights global pandemics are inevitable
there's too much movement to keep
viruses isolated we should acknowledge
that yes we can do our best to keep
foreign diseases out of this country but
we ought to spend most of our time
trying to figure out how to protect
Americans once the diseases get here
there's still a lot we don't know about
the Chinese coronavirus but two things
do seem clear it is highly communicable
and the elderly and people with
pre-existing respiratory disease face
the greatest threat from it that means
for most Americans the biggest risks
will come not from the virus itself but
from its ancillary effects people will
panic Travel will be disrupted markets
will tumble and most critically
hospitals will be overwhelmed we're
about to learn the limits of our health
care system conditions will be tough for
the many thousands of Americans looking
for beds to recover from the flu in
Seattle they already are but things will
be even worse for anyone suffering from
say pancreatitis or a burst appendix not
to mention countless other health
emergencies people like this may not get
care at all our system won't be able to
accommodate them there are many
implications of this and some of them
are political for example is this really
the time to invite the rest of the world
to join Medicare for all probably not
that idea was always stupid now it's
clearly dangerous on a practical level
saving American medicine from collapse
must be our leaders top priority right
now we need to expand emergency hospital
bed capacity we need to make certain we
have enough life-saving drugs and
medical equipment the basics
unfortunately that's not as simple as it
sounds or as it should be well the rest
of us who are arguing about sexism and
transgendered bathrooms China took
control of our health care system
China dominates the world market in
pharmaceutical ingredients compounds
used in virtually every essential
medicine for high blood pressure for
cancer for Alzheimer's disease and many
more come from China so the key
components in vital medical technology
CT scanners x-ray machines ultrasounds
as of tonight more than 95% of all the
antibiotics in America are manufactured
in communist China 95 percent our chief
global rival has a total man
Polly on the most important medicine in
the world that should worry you more
than anything the candidates are
currently talking about imagine watching
one of your children die from an
infected cut china has the power to make
that happen the Chinese government is
acutely aware of this power last year a
prominent Chinese economist suggested
cutting off the supply of antibiotics to
the United States as leverage in the
trade war that should have been the
biggest story in America the news media
all but ignored it why because it
implicated them and their political
party in one of the greatest crimes of
our time
nine years ago famously brilliant former
President Barack Obama did predict a
connection between China and the next
global pandemic
unfortunately Obama got it backward he
claimed China would help us I absolutely
believe that China's peaceful rise is
good for the world and it's good for
America to the extent that we have a
partner in addressing issues like
climate change or pandemic our foremost
genius the people in charge have no idea
what they're doing and to the extent
they do they're selling us out on
purpose we should have seen this coming
in recent weeks you've heard a lot about
disruption to our so-called supply
chains think about what that means it
means that thanks to economic changes
that made a small group of business
moguls incredibly rich we no longer make
the things we need to survive and
prosper as a nation people who hate us
and who seek to displace us make those
things and it's not just medicines and
x-ray machines it's computers and phones
and robotics and automotive components
and machine tools and essential parts
for aircraft engines etc in fact apart
from fossil fuels
it's almost everything and now you may
have noticed many of our leaders are
talking about shutting down our domestic
energy sector the last independent part
of the American economy
this is sabotage and we're about to
learn how undermined we've been at some
point our leaders should be held to
account for this for now we need to work
as if our lives depended on it to fix
this problem global warming isn't the
existential threat we face extortion
from China is in very real ways that
Chinese government controls us there is
no greater national security danger than
the one they posed to
bond we need a modern martial plan one
designed to rebuild essential American
manufacturing we should start tomorrow
with medicine and technology to fight
the corona virus and then with
antibiotics some will oppose the idea
because it poses a threat to
arrangements they currently benefit from
but a majority of Americans will welcome
it gladly
even in the Congress manufacturing lifts
every congressional district it
shouldn't be hard to win bipartisan
support no doubt the sages on television
will denounce any acknowledgment of
China's threat as racism or intolerance
Joe Biden's already done that ignore
them
the Chinese coronavirus really is
Chinese it arose in that country for the
same reason American businesses have
sent so many of our jobs there lacks
health and safety standards and endemic
corruption China did this to the world
and we should not pretend otherwise
that's not xenophobia it's true the most
bitter irony of all of that is that a
few years from now when every last
victim of this virus has recovered or
been buried the Chinese government could
easily grow stronger because of this
disaster and America weaker China
unleashes a pandemic and then overtakes
the US as a result that's too horrible
an outcome to contemplate and too
dangerous for us we ought to do
everything we can to make certain it
does not happen now let's start by
accurately describing what is happening
the Chinese quarter virus isn't some
fluke of globalization it is the
inevitable byproduct of it exotic
diseases and the mass destruction they
cause are the built-in cost of
connectedness and they always will be
the people have told us there was no
downside to living in a borderless world
were lying make them eat their words
strip them of their power never listen
to them again in fact and this is still
the hardest thing for official
Washington to accept this pandemic
vindicates Donald Trump's entire
political thesis on the big things
Trump was right trade immigration
manufacturing globalization these are
the issues our ruling class assiduously
ignores and has ignored for decades in
favor of silly calculated distractions
like gender warfare and race politics
things that defied us
Trump by Contra
rain on the issues that mattered and he
won precisely because the public was
tired of being lied to and he should
remember that the White House reaction
the corner of iris so far has been
uneven and limp but it doesn't need to
be the blueprint for an effective
response response that not only protects
this country but improves it he's right
there in the president's 2016 acceptance
speech of the Republican convention in
Cleveland Americanism not globalism will
be the credo he said we are going to
start building and making things again
all we need to do is start believing in
ourselves in our country again it is
time to show the world that America is
back bigger and better and stronger than
ever before
there it is that's the governing agenda
in the age of the Chinese coronavirus
abandoned globalism rebuild the country
make the things we need a strong America
is an independent America there's no
other way